if you ask real experts in probability
they'll say this is not random because
it's far too uniform you know really
poisson that kind of thing would have
more gaps and so forth but it's random
enough and what i'm about to show you
works with any sufficiently random dots
okay now i photocopy this on a
transparency the exact copy i put one on
top of the other the result is this
interestingly boring shall i say really
amazingly boring but now let's shift the
transparency against the bottom sheet a
little bit and what you see is this
you see
those concentric circles
around
a common center and the reason actually
in retrospect is not too surprising
because whatever i'm doing to the
transparency is a euclidean motion and
we know that euclidean motion in 2d is
always a rotation actually it could be a
translation but translation is like
rotation with the center at infinity so
it's always a rotation so you see
um those
traces of rotation so to speak under
your eyes now the what's happening is
that you see the original random dots
are displaced slightly
and the image is close enough to the
original dots
and when you have a situation like that
human eyes cannot help connecting the
dots you know those dots are connected
and you see those small segments in your
eyes and then you see those trajectories
of the rotation
concentric circles so if you rotate them
too far the images and originals get too
far and they lose all correlation and
you don't see anything okay now but
suppose that for example this common
center of all the concentric circle is
too high and you don't want them it'll
be too high you want to bring it back to
the center so when i first tried this i
naturally shifted the transparency in
the direction that i wanted to move the
center but watch what happens when i do
this i'm going to move it up and down in
this direction
then the center moves sideways
horizontally and when i move the
transparency
sideways it goes up and down
so the motion of the center is always
perpendicular to the direction in which
i'm moving the transparency that's
really strange
now once you notice this you can
actually figure out figure out what's
happening by calculation so let's say
that this is a line and that's another
line and it's been one has been rotated
into other and so that's the center of
rotation that's where they intersect so
to speak now let's say that i move the
image sideways and you can see that the
the point of intersection actually goes
up and down
like that
so although i'm moving the knife
horizontally the intersection point is
going up and down vertically so that's
more that's why if you move the thing
horizontally transparency horizontally
the center goes vertically and if you
move it vertically it goes horizontally
next i'm going to show you another
example this is
the same picture as the previous one but
only shrunk a little bit i went to the
photocopier and hit the shrink button it
shouldn't be shrunk too much um maybe
this is 96 of the original because if
you shrink it too much again you do the
correlation you don't see anything
but this time what you see is this
you see those spirals
and of course you see those spirals
because in addition to the rotation
that's already present from the previous
one
you rescale the whole thing so you have
this
radio
shrinking and if i now
adjust the rotation so that so as to get
rid of the rotational component and make
it pure
translation then you get this radial
pattern okay so that was the random end
of the experiment let's try the other
end which is the regular end of the
spectrum
and we'll begin by seeing something that
is very classical well known and this
kind of thing makes you seasick um you
know square lattice and i took an exact
photocopy of this on the transparency
and if i put one on top of the other you
get something completely black yeah
now nothing interesting is happening
let's start rotating this
when i rotate this
some ghost like sort of shades up here
and resolved into
resolve into
this beautiful
pattern of square lattice but at 45
degrees the original one
and as i keep rotating
it resolves into smaller smaller pattern
and at around 45 degrees it becomes the
smallest and around that point you see
there's some sort of wave that comes in
and out that's quite curious
and then when i keep spinning
eventually
this pattern becomes larger and larger
comes back out at us
again
45 degrees and then the scale diverges
and then becomes a blur and it keeps
going and so and
i have rotated by 90 degrees because
that's the period if you like this is
called a moire pattern and which is
quite well known you can do the same
thing with another kind of lattice this
is lots and lots of equilateral
triangles that have been put together
and colored in alternated fashion black
and white and if i
put the photocopy of this on top again
you see nothing now let's start rotating
this you again see the moire pattern a
ghost comes in and then resolve into
this kind of thing i think at this stage
most people see
black walls partitioning the plane into
white triangles black walls and white
triangles okay
let's keep rotating
these triangles become smaller and
smaller
and they kind of go away and resolve
into the smallest scale
and then
if i keep rotating these
come back
but when they come back at us what comes
back is not want what went out many
people at this stage see hexagons
but you can probably be convinced that
these are also white walls dividing the
playing into black triangles i don't
know if you can see this
and so what comes out back is dual to
what went went out what went out was
black walls dividing playing into white
triangles but what came back is white
walls divine implying to lock triangles
and then it
becomes a blur
and if i keep
rotating you
get back what has just disappeared into
infinity
and then if you keep rotating further
you again get
hexagons and
go into small scale and eventually
the pattern starts coming back but what
comes back is what had gone out in the
first place that is black walls with
white triangles and then it becomes a
blur and by the time i completed the
cycle i have rotated by 120 degrees
which is the angle of symmetry but
within this same
single period it turns out that you have
two subperiods and those two superiors
are dual to each other what goes out and
what comes back and so are sort of
complementary to each other so that's
quite curious
number five is brought to you by the
mathematical sciences research institute
msri
that's the building behind me there this
is a place where many of the world's top
mathematicians come together for
sometimes a semester at a time cracking
some of the hardest problems in
mathematics if you'd like to find out
more i'll put some links in the
description under the video